for the tampa bay rays it will be
left-hander ryan yarborough looking to
get back on track making his 21st start
of the season
another 2-2
that's a liner to right for a base hit
ground ball deep third diving backhand
is topped by diaz
look to second stopped didn't have a
grip through the first pulled choy it'll
be a base hit for a scope that's a break
for the tigers
diaz made a great diving stop i think he
might have gotten badou at second or
maybe he saw badou is so close to second
that he then pulled the ball down
he got it cocked the corner says junior
valentine
grossman not happy with that call that
was a party word he thought it was wide
and is out number one
ground ball deep short stopped by
wendell throw to third got him
diaz just got that foot on the bag ahead
of badou
he thinks he might have gotten in there
but
the call made by jerry meals down at
third base and the tigers will not have
that looked at two house and here comes
jamer candelario
the 1-0
that is pounded deep center field back
goes phillips and that is gone a home
run
for jamer candelario
mad power to center field it's a
three-run bomb
derek skubal was outstanding his last
timeout making his 27th start of the
season
lau on the ground to jonathan scope
three ground ball outs and ten pitches
for tarik skubal to start this saturday
afternoon good start for the tigers
offensively
there's a shot down the left field line
that ball is gone
a solo bullet off the bat of dustin
garneau
he continues his red hot extra best
hitting streak he's got home run number
five
he's the one that's setting the tone not
me ground ball is going to go through
the left side between goodram and
candelario a little lead off single for
margaux who blow the dh he has 10 home
runs everybody else in double figures as
well there's a high fly ball back into
left the dude's going to watch it sail
that one it's gone
that's home run number 11.
well the rays for the first time have
everybody in the lineup in double
figures and home runs
and luke lowe has not hit them all in a
range uniform but that's a big one for
him there
to cut the deficit in half
out of fielder's choice scored on the
candelario home run in the first inning
takes this one into right that ball is
charged by margot he got it margot
charging in
makes a sliding catch
that ball started to dive on him out
there and he got there to make the crab
yawning
yeah i don't know how it could be
anybody else i agree fly ball into left
center going to fall for a base hit a
big hop in front of hill big turn there
by rosarita at first and he's aboard
with a two-out single
there he goes
and it's followed away
candelaria he's got it and he puts it
away big out for terrence
2-2
school
into center field phillips will go back
still on the move still going gets there
at the track and makes the catch
phillips hit the deck on the track picks
up that knee a little bit but he makes
the grab and gets a tip of the cap
from ryan yarbrough and he'll turn it
over
now to jose arena
that's another hit for luke lowe beats
it
center field margot is going to go to
third
and the rays will put men on the corners
luplow after the first pitch and the
raise with a major threat already
ground ball
right side
out at second and
out at first the rays will get the run
4-6-3 on that double play as margaux
crosses the plate making it 4-3
puts down the bunt yarbrough off the
mound bare-handed pickup and that
underhanded toss
and choy
is
hurt and i think
valentine is going to call hill out for
running outside the runners lane
he is down
and joy
to walk off
that
discomfort in the hand and hill is down
back at first and he will be attended to
by the detroit trainer so
no big help into the cart so the bases
are empty for manuel margot
want to know
ground ball that's fair inside the bag
at first up the line
margot is going to turn it on heading
for second and he is safe he got that
hand in
before the tag
on the ground willy castro throws him
out austin meadows first pitch swinging
and willie castro was positioned
well for detroit in the shift to give it
a one run tigers lead as we head to the
center
sharply hit nice stop loud up and out
with the throw
to retire castro
one two three
we go to the bottom of the seventh
innings
and now the swing
and a miss the ball gets away
cenino is out but the runner at first
moves to second so zunino strikes out
and garneau had that ball pop away from
him
and choi
winds up at second base so phillips is
it first
and troy at second now yandy diaz
sends one to deep left field grossman
has got it
and a long out for yandi diaz who just
missed it ends the seventh
a rose arena taps it in front garneau
nice play
boy that's getting out of the box quick
for dustin garneau
no play at all there for funkhouser
that's all going to be on the catcher
he's got to react immediately and
i mean as soon as a rose arena was going
so is garneau it's a great play great
throw
[Applause]
high drive based in off the 02 pitch
0-2 fastball and margot took it right
back through the middle
for his third hit of the day on for the
fourth time
and he shoots it the other way into left
he has a base hit
that pushes margot up to second
nomado's not wasting any time serves
that one the other way and the range had
two men on with two men out
the one two
jammed it popped it up left side
candelario foul territory he's got it
and a huge out recorded there by kyle
funkhouser it's all about michael former
right now looking for his 10th save of
the season
3-2 did he go he did not and there's a
walk
and wendell is hit by that pitch
now he'll face yandy diaz
first pitch swinging on the ground get
it there's one
the double play turn and the tigers hold
on and beat him for three
you